buenas noches lo que hace lo que se ha
sabido es que mariano gonzález tenía
previsto estrechar el cerco policial y
capturar al ex secretario presidencial
bruno pacheco al ex ministro de
transportes juan silva ya los sobrinos
del mandatario fray vázquez y gianmarco
castillo esto habría disgustado al
presidente de los peruanos y a través de
un twitter ordenó su destitución
intentando poner paños fríos sobre esta
crisis política del primer ministro
aníbal torres justificó la salida de
mariano casi o del gobierno de perón de
mariano gonzález el gobierno de pedro
castillo y señaló que su alejamiento se
debe porque a su entender el ministro
gonzález no habría cumplido los alcances
para disminuir la inseguridad ciudadana
por su parte benji espinoza abogado de
pedro castillo señaló que el mandatario
está evaluando
denunciar por difamación al ex ministro
del interior y a propósito de lo que
dice gonzález la fiscal de la nación liz
benavides citó al ex ministro para tomar
su declaración por ellos que podrían ser
delitos y la junta de portavoces del
congreso se reunión para tratar esta
cuestión cuestión cuéntenos qué
consecuencias podría enfrentar el
presidente
como usted bien lo ha dicho la junta de
portavoces se reunió y ellos han
declarado que se muestran favorables a
una tercera moción de vacancia
presidencial contra pedro castillo en
realidad la situación del mandatario
está muy crítica porque no solamente va
a tener que afrontar un proceso de
impeachment que están preparando los
congresistas sino también un juicio
político que esperan se concrete por
corrupción además de las investigaciones
que realiza la fiscalía pero casi no
tiene las cosas muy difíciles y a esta
hora diversas organizaciones civiles
como pro ética están pidiendo la salida
de pedro casi o del gobierno y están
señalando que debe realizarse un
adelanto de elecciones para finalmente
poner solución a la crisis política que
viene atravesando perú desde hace muchos
meses y mientras tanto ha habido otras
denuncias por ejemplo el general peruano
césar manuel vallejos presentó su
renuncia irrevocable al cargo del
director general de inteligencia
cuéntenos qué otras consecuencias podría
haber en el gabinete
bueno en realidad esta situación pone en
riesgo no solamente al primer ministro
de aníbal torres sino también a todo su
gabinete de el consejo de estado por lo
pronto el parlamento ha citado a aníbal
torres para que expliqué a los
legisladores cuál es el sustento que
lleva a la destitución de mariano
gonzález y por qué pedro castillo optó
de esa manera y se va a ver en las
próximas horas qué es lo que declara el
primer ministro y si no convence al
parlamento puede ser objeto de una
moción de censura que finalmente obligue
su destitución